so if you were to somehow
get inside the brain of any
authoritarian
you would find that their fantasies
aren't the conventional fantasies
an authoritarian fantasizes about
controlling you and coronavirus has
given the perfect pretext to do that
now they force their way into your home
you're not going to believe this story
rick leventhal has it for us hey rick
hey tucker for
anyone in new york or california it'll
be a holiday season like no
other two governors with similar
mandates arguing the only way to slow
the spread of covet 19
is to start shutting down again starting
this friday night
a 10 p.m curfew will be in effect for
every bar restaurant gym and liquor
store in the state of new york
restaurants can still serve food
curbside for pickup or delivery but no
alcohol to go and indoor and outdoor
gatherings on your own property will be
limited to no more than 10 people
governor andrew cuomo says the parties
are the problem blaming them for the
spike in cases
and says if the new restrictions don't
slow the spread he may shut down gyms
and indoor dining altogether and he's
demanding new york city's mayor
deploy the nypd to enforce the new
there are rules two
fundamental truths in this situation
it's individual discipline
and its government enforcement
and over here on the left coast governor
gavin newsom has issued similar new
guidelines ahead of the thanksgiving
holiday
no more than three households can gather
together at a time
gatherings must be outside and last
two hours or less attendees can use
restrooms as long as they're frequently
sanitized
and singing chanting and shouting are
strongly
discouraged tucker i swear
i did not make these up i was literally
just thinking that exact same thing
rick leventhal has gone rogue he's
writing fake news again no
i didn't i didn't do it i'm just i'm
just telling you what he said
it's just unbelievable so much is rick
leventhal thank you for that
sure